لا يزال من المثير للإعجاب مشاهدة
تحركات ميك جاغر في سن 78 عامًا ،
لكن كيف لم يتخذ أي شخص آخر خطوة
للتعرف على ميك ميك الذي صنع هذه
الصورة لجاغر بمفرده وهو يحتسي بيرة
في حانة غطس.
الصالون القندس العطش
الذي يعتقد أنه وصل بعد أن غادر ميك ،
لم يذكر أحد حقًا أن أي شخص
مشهور كان هنا ، لذا لا أعتقد
أنهم لاحظوا آه ولكن هذا الصباح
فعل هاتفي لأن ميك جاغر
نفسه نشر الصورة على تويتر
قائلاً بالخارج وفي الداخل  شارلوت نورث
كارولينا القندس العطش هو أسطورة محلية
للمطورين الباقين على قيد الحياة الذين اضطروا إلى البناء
حولها عندما ظهرت أسطورة موسيقى الروك
ولم يتعرف عليه أحد ، فقد
تطايرت التعليقات
حول ميك جاغر الذي كان يحتسي بيرة
خلفك إلى
يمينه  كان لديهم تذاكر لحفل شارلوت الحجارة
حتى 400 ليذهبوا إلى
العرض ويقتربوا قدر المستطاع من ميك
وأه لو أنهم استداروا فقط
لكانوا أقرب ما يكون  نظرًا لأنهم
سيحصلون على أي وقت مضى ، لم يكن أحد على
الأقل يشير إليك ،
حتى أن النادل لم يلاحظ أن
كاتبًا محليًا واحدًا جيريمي ماركوفيتش
سطع الصورة بحثًا عن
ملابس.حسّن الكمبيوتر البيرة
ولكن محاولات تحديد ما
يشربه ميك  كان ماركوفيتش مازحًا عديم الجدوى من
الناس الذين يعيشون في
قضبان من الطوب لا يجب ألا
تغني الحجارة عن هذا النوع من الأماكن
[تصفيق]
لم يكن المالك المشارك لهذا الهونكي تونك
يروي عطش جاغر باللون الأزرق الذي جلبه
إليه
كما نشر أحد المعجبين أحصل على بيرة
يبدو أن رجلاً يحصل على البيرة ميك جاغر
يحصل على بيرة يبدو وكأنه غلاف ألبوم موسيقى الروك الكلاسيكي
cnn
new york